non-minimalists
do you guys have any tips on getting rid
of things
during the covid restrictions
so i've got a pithy answer for you here
ryan so getting rid of things during
covet as soon as that question came in i
agreed with it i'm like yeah i guess it
is more difficult
i'm like wait a minute wait a minute so
here's my pithy answer and then one
packet
even the best excuse is still an excuse
why is it actually more difficult to get
rid of things during covet in a weird
way
it should be even easier because you're
surrounded you're confronted by the
stuff more you're at home more
frequently
yeah it's been easier for me man for
sure yeah although
finding a place to donate to has been a
little bit more difficult yes i do have
a box of donations sitting in the back
of my trunk that's been there for
a couple weeks we found a good wheel
that was open yeah and
it's on uh the one in our neighborhood
was
closed i think it's closed permanently
there's but anyway there was one
uh neighborhood over basically i'll give
you that address after all this
but um also you can find places that
pick up stuff for you
as well donationtown.org is a great
resource
for you that's what i should do yeah and
so places will pick stuff up especially
if
you have big ticket items you have a big
furniture or something you want to get
rid of a couch or a mattress
a lot of these places are non-profits
and you'll find responsible non-profits
in your area
that's how i found when we lived in in
missoula i found the donation warehouse
was from
donationtown.org and they'll pick up
your mattresses and they
they repurpose them to uh people who
have been victims of abuse
or people who are were formerly homeless
and they
recently have come out of that situation
and and they need
the essentials and so you can find
a place on donationtown.org that will
help other people with your stuff that
is just accumulating
dust wherever you are you have a pithy
answer for v hall
i do i do before i get to my pithy
answer uh i think with kovid
there's this mindset of you don't want
to declutter right now because
you know we're in an emergency type
situation
and you never know what kind of things
you'll need
but you know to your point now is the
best time
to declutter because if you're saying
you're sitting around with a bunch of
junk right now that you don't need
during covid
you're probably not going to need it
outside of coven or any other
or any other emergency so my pithy
answer is this the best time to
declutter was yesterday
the second best time is today yeah so
v hall stop making excuses but
you know we're again we're not here to
judge right um but an excuse is an
excuse
indeed and so you bring up the you you
brought up the word emergency
and i like that because we have another
rule in the the minimalist
rule book called the emergency items
rule so we
often are allergic to just in case items
because
just in case enables us to hold on to
everything so there's another rule in
that book called the 2020 rule that
allows you to get rid of just the case
items
but there's a small sub set the
subcategory of just in case items are
useful we call that
we call them emergency items and hence
the emergency item
rule and the thing i like about this
rule is it is situational and so it
changes as your life changes when you
and i lived in
montana we actually needed a few more
emergency items right
because there's winter yeah yeah yes and
it's
it's not a fun winter there right no
winter here in l.a
right right here it's like some late
summer yeah
and so uh the thing about these
emergency items we have to be really
honest about what we need
and ryan you hit the nail on the head
kovit actually illuminates
how absurd most of the emergency items
we thought we
needed were yeah what about all those
buckets of food people are holding on to
right now like they still haven't had to
dip into the buckets right right
or if they did i i need to see video of
it like right oh i can't imagine how bad
the bucket food is i think there are
we're talking about the jim baker stuff
right yeah there's like youtube channels
where they review
buck bucket food oh wow yeah cause i
was like looking at uh during the
earthquake like when we had a big
earthquake i was looking at like
oh how to get prepared for an earthquake
and i came across the
somehow i came across the bucket of food
reviews anyway
it's interesting because dude you're
it's like yeah it's like it's like a you
know a food review
but it's for a bucket of food it's nuts
right now
we did a podcast episode i think it was
with tk coleman
about preparation and let me see if i
can find it here
the thing we talked about though is like
there are certain things that we have as
uh yeah it was episode 224 so we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
episode 224 of the minimalist podcast so
the title of it was pandemic preparation
but it was really about how little we
need but there are some things
that you and i have like i have a few
cases of like five cases of sardines now
i ate sardines regularly so it's not
like they're
just sitting there going to waste yeah
but that that's my
food bucket effectively i mean i've got
like i probably have two weeks worth of
like freezer
meat meat in my freezer uh
yeah but i mean i don't feel like i need
more than that yeah
because even if let's say the stores
closed down you know i'd have basically
two weeks to formulate a plan
um but having six months worth of food
what does that do because let's say you
are in a situation
where you have to you know have a food
reserve for six months
well what do you do on that seventh
month so maybe you should have a seventh
month food supply
right i mean it's just endless no matter
how much you prepare
you can't be prepared for everything and
in that episode go back and listen to it
if you're interested because
we talk about time frames and what ryan
and i prepare for
and how we differ a little bit as well
so you can check that out episode
224.